like hello not mentally but like i'm i'm alive physically my brain might not be in this plane of existence but like my soul might not be here but my physical disgusting human husk of a body is here
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I lost the nap, gotcha.
Yet again.
I keep thinking the rates are so shit.
But I keep thinking this is it.
I'm going to get my pity right here.
Right now.
I will get the pity roll.
Well, I never learned.
And I was like, I'm just gonna, I'm gonna take a little two to three hour nap-a-roony, and then I will feel so refreshed.
Because this is it.
This is that moment.
It's gonna happen.
Today's the day.
And then it's never that day.
I don't understand.
Why is it never today?
I work so hard.
Why is it never to that today?
Folly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tired, eh?
Mr. Broken Volly, thank you.
Lajenta, super.
Thank you.
Hey, Jokey.
So here's an idea for the next game to play Halo 2.
It's the easiest one to finish.
It only takes two to three streams to finish.
Honestly, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're so asleep.
This is just a figment of your imagination.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
But yeah.
Um, it was so messed up.
Because I literally I got I set up in line right for like five.
Like I even pushed it to six because I knew I knew today I was like not like when I was making that schedule because you know I posted a schedule at two in the morning.
Um, so I was like, I know I ain't gonna wake up.
I know I won't be ready at 5 p.m.
I knew it.
Like, in my heart, I was like, don't kid yourself, Doki.
Today's not the 5 p.m.
day.
I know.
Like, we always do 5 p.m.
PST.
But, like, I was just like, who are you kidding, Doki?
You posted your schedule at 2 in the morning.
You're not okay.
You need that extra hour.
I was like, like the random 6 p.m.
You know, whenever I put 6 p.m.
Like, you're like, something's wrong.
Like, something happens on that day.
Like, like, something is going on, like, if she posts, like, because it's just so weird.
Like, usually, it's rarely ever, it's 6 p.m.
I've always been, like, 5 p.m.
on the dot.
But it's like, I knew, and I was like, I knew it.
I was like, like i told you i told you like it was a sign and it did my body knew could read the fucking future
but it's like i set my alarm at 5 45 um i woke up but i was just like oh no I didn't get the gotcha.
I was like, I don't understand though.
Like, surely like some, something will be different.
Like, surely, I was like, I thought today was the day though.
I don't understand.
Was today not the day?
Why did it not?
Sorry, that was an echo of you.
oh yeah if you heard that i was trying to pull up the you're like whoa double dokey's like for five seconds i was trying to pull up my fucking uh uh the the the donation chat because like i keep two different chats open one for like super chats and the other one for a regular chat so like i was just doing that um anyway um and then you know obviously obviously uh um i got up like I should have got up a little I like fucking marinated in the bed for like 10 minutes and then and then I was like oh I should get up
sure I can set everything up in 10 minutes right I was like oh man I I can set up everything in 10 minutes it's fine I'll do I then I got up Got on my PC.
I was just like...
Just stared off, like, into the void.
And I'm just like, I stared off into the void.
And I was just like...
Because afraid I was, like, slowly booting up, I guess.
And I was like, wait, what time is it?
605.
Oh.
I nearly...
10 minutes have passed.
I was like, oh, no, it's, I guess, what?
It's 605.
Oh, shit, okay, I guess, okay, I got it set up now.
I got it.
I was like, oh, no, it's, it's 605.
Yeah, I was downloading the Doki updates in between.
There was a new patch, a new patch notes that came out.
Like, I'm Doki.
It was at 2.1 or some shit.
The boy to blink them back.
Man-Tide.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you.
Watch the director's cut of the concert.
Next day, got the job I wanted.
Coincidence?
I think not.
Thanks for the luck.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys enjoyed the director's.
I know I should have made the waiting room a lot earlier.
But, like, I was like, fuck it.
Because I got the file.
I did tell you guys.
I was like, we might potentially get the video by the end of the week.
I did say it.
I got the file.
And I was just like, upload.
And I was just like, all right.
That's enough of a war.
That's enough time.
I know I should give you guys more of a waiting period.
But I was just like, bro, I got the file.
And to be fair, like.
um it's not like it was like super new there were like i mean like it is a director's cut so we did have like you know a new song the encore and uh like the new choreo uh for escape for the city and and like uh refreshed new like small little edits for like um visuals and stuff so yeah i was so happy with um it did take a while to do like all the um to get the polished version out like yeah It was much more polished and everything like all the little things I wanted to fix got fixed and everything But yes,
I told you guys you would not expect the encore I was like you're not never gonna guess the song I picked for the encore I I was like you guys ain't gonna expect as I was so proud of myself I was like oh my I was so proud of myself for the encore song that I fit because it was like it was genius like because who the fuck would i don't know who the fuck would do han solo and who the fuck would do i'm han solo um at a v for a vtuber concert but i was just like bro i've always wanted to do the connect dance and it's like it's so easy to really do the trash compactor i think my favorite one is the um fuck i don't remember what it's called the fucking the little bike thing that was my favorite move i honestly that's it's like and then the shoulder polish yeah the shoulder polish yeah that one was good too yeah i felt like i love the one person who did the edit where they put the fucking um star wars connect dance symbols and like star wars connect shit like on the side like to like like as
if we're actually playing the connect okay you guys i'm idea that song has been living rent free in my head for fucking years ever since i think like ever since like john tron and game crumbs did that like the the series i guess it was john i yeah like oh my god like ever since like john tron did the fucking original video of the the star wars connection like oh my god and then like he did the remaster and where the game crumbs were a guest and stuff on um on at the end like i that's been like in my head i feel like i've been like thinking about that song for so fucking long and i was like you know it i had to make that my dreams come true i was like that's why i became a youtube i was just like one day i will dance i
I had to do it like I with great power comes great shitposts don't let your dreams be dreams I had it was the only chance I get it's such a good song I just found out when I did the the the when I did like the the song recording for it because they were like who's the artist and I never thought of like I never thought about how this song was an actual real song I thought they made this song just for the Star Wars connect but then I found out that like this was a real song and it was from fucking Jason DeRule what's his name Jason DeRuleau I just found out it's a real fucking song I didn't realize it was a it was a pair I thought they were like well I can't believe they this is such a good song that they made um for for this to connect and then they I realized they had um a lot of like other pairs like it's not just Han Solo like there's other songs in the game like I know I I was like what they do it's I was like what more than just i'm on solo there's other songs um you know which is
which in hindsight they're they're yeah like they're in hindsight yeah because it's a dance game so they had why i don't know if you guys know this but they have ymca as well um but it's like the okay the lyrics for it is so because i was like at that point i was in my own little rabbit hole of like all the other like stupid fucking parodies that they do.
Let me see if I can find it.
Okay.
Star Wars.
I remember one of them was like YMCA, but it was like it was different.
It was very it was like it was the same, but also it was Boba Fett dancing too, which is pretty fucking funny.
It was actually a lot.
There's so much more and a lot of them are so stupid.
Okay, so YMCA, it starts off as like, oh, okay, it's the same.
And then instead of YMCA, it's, let me say I can find it.
I need it.
Oh, it's okay.
It be in the empire today.
It's great to be in the empire today.
This is not the sound to say, but it's like, it's great to be in the empire today.
And it's when Boba Fett and the Stormtrooper was like, empire today.
So it's like a propaganda song.
Cause I was like, wait, this is YMCA.
Cause it's like young men.
I don't need to feel down.
I said young men It's like it's great to be in the empire today.
Yeah, it's great to be in the empire Because I was like, oh shit, it's just YMCA and But they changed that.
I was like, what the fuck?
So for those who don't hear it, it's literally this And it's like and it's the fucking stormtroopers like fucking grooving at it.
so yeah i was like in my little own rabbit hole of like connect star wars because i was like what other songs are there but i will say obviously um um i'm hot solo what is the best one is is the is the best one but it was the other ones are also like pretty good like the uh oh yeah hologram girl instead of a holograph girl uh they're all they're all good in their own way but ihan solo like transcends reality it just it's like in its own fucking tier um but yeah no it was i'm so happy i was actually able to do that song and i think the Okay,
I was reading the comments.
Also, like, I was like, I was like, oh my god.
I, I was like, knew you guys were not expecting it.
Because who the fuck would see?
Like, VTuber concerts are so expensive.
So it's like, who the fuck would waste it on I'm Han Solo?
But like, who the fuck wouldn't take that opportunity?
Like, boom, I had thousands of dollars gone.
But so worth it.
Yeah.
I feel like for me, my entire, like, when I do performances, I just, like, I sing songs that I know, like, and perform songs that I know, like, no one else would fucking do.
Like, fucking do.
Because they're like, we gotta be serious here.
Like, this is a lot of money going into it.
I'm just like, this is a lot of money to make my shitpost come true.
up everyone could sing like i don't know the the idol anime song that you know we all know and love like we could i could also sing um i i could also sing uh i'm on solo like because at least i'd be the first one you know like you know oh my gosh i'm trying to think like I could be like um the 80th vtuber to sing this really popular vocaloid song or like this very popular oh my god what's that singer name I ate auto song but I could be the first vtuber to sing I'm on solo I could be the very first vtuber
Yeah, I am a pioneer.
Yeah, I could have made the 1,000th 3D performance of your idol, but I was the first to do I'm on solo.
And then what was funny was that I saw like, like I was reading the comments and, um, the pioneer of the arts.
Bravo.
You're so, you're a genius, Doki.
I'm a visionary.
Um, anyway, so I saw like the comments, you know, and someone was like, how is she able to get like permission from Disney and Star Wars and Lucas films to do this cover?
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, getting permission.
Yeah, I was like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, yeah, quote, like, getting the permission to do this.
Yeah, I'm just like, for those who don't know, as a fair use of the odds is pretty fun, but, um, um, yeah, so like, as an indie, It's just they just take they just take the money like like obviously the concert is not it's technically Monetized but monetized in a way where the music owners take the money So so they get the money,
but that's okay because like, you know Yeah, just I just don't tell Disney, but like, you know, you can do cover songs It's just you can't monetize them So yeah, mostly permissions are for corporations.
Like I'm just a little guy.
So like, yeah.
So obviously, like it's most for like a lot of indies who are able to do like the songs where usually you get perms if you host an actual real.
You have to get perms if you host an actual real concert where people have to pay for tickets.
If it's just like a free performance and like nothing is sold.
there's no like sales or anything um to like watch uh watch the uh concert then like you can upload it like on the internet like you don't have to worry about royalties and stuff because it's like um it's considered fine like uh just because like you're not actually monetizing it through like uh um through like sales of like like for like sales to like tickets and stuff to people um because like that's why like the phantom thief concert was never uploaded on uh like on any platforms like the official one because like i said like um some of the songs we can't even like put it online because like we don't have the perms for that like uh perms to put it online because we sold tickets for it um we have songs to perform it at the concert but we're not allowed to put it online just because like uh just because we did sold tickets to the phantom thief concert but Like the recordings is fine because it's like,
you know, fans recorded it.
So there's like, it's like such, it's like there's so many laws behind it and stuff.
But because this concert was free, it's free.
And we didn't monetize in any way.
Like, you know, you just have to be at anime.
And anime expo had it their own little like rule where like any song can be performed at anime expo.
as long as like um like because they have their own little uh i don't know what's called rules and regulation regarding like copyrights for music performances so like as long as like you know we don't sell tickets for it like any song can be performed there so because of that i'm like yay yeah so it's just a little bit of like an insight on like concerts and stuff like music rights are so fucking complicated i um i hate like i hate going over music rights stuff because like it's so fucking complicated and stuff you gotta like like if you do want to like uh host like an actual real concert with like ticket sales and you know live streaming tickets you have to get like a music lawyer to look through like each song to be like to make sure it's allowed It was so,
I remember during the Phantom Feature, it was so complicated because there's so many songs we wanted to do, but we couldn't because of like, oh, the song, you can do cover songs of it online, but you can't perform it.
The IP laws are so confusing.
Like you can do like cover songs of it.
But you have to pay for it.
Licensing fee.
But then you can't do like concert performance of this.
And even, and then there's some songs where you can do conference, uh, concert, not concert, concert, there's some songs where you can do concert performances but you have to pay licensing fee and then you also have to like uh but then like there's the process of the license licensing um is like so long too um but then like uploading it online is also a different fee as well so it's just there's so much stuff going on with it next day thank you the super chat thank you thank you he has the nap gotcha ever worked for you in your entire life i don't think it's a gotcha it's super chat thank you one time i remember one time it was beautiful and i've been trying to chase that high ever since that one time where i did win the gosh it was so beautiful and i'm like i might i must experience that again like i'm so writing that i still remember and every time i take that nap i'm like i need to feel that again i need to feel it again
i'm really gambling it was it was incredible i felt like i was a whole different person and i'm Like, I gotta know, I gotta feel it, kid.
I can't, I can't, this can't be the only time.
I gotta know what it was like again.
It was so beautiful.
But yeah, no, the music industry is like, it's so fucking stupid.
I mean, it's like, it's just like, I feel like it's just music labels.
Because like music labels, are there to fuck with people um since the dawn of time so like music companies so like it's always been like that even with spotify you guys didn't know when spotify first uh came out like when they first like um um what's the word when spotify first came into being like music labels were like fuck spotify like we don't want to work with spot like now all of them are like you know working with spotify now um but like even then like back then they're like we don't want to put our music online yeah um and it's not even the thing is usually it's not even the music artists that get the money it's just the fucking the CEOs and like the producers of the music labels that take majority of the money too it's not like it's going back to the artists in general too that's the park um um like the producers pocket majority of the funds yeah the label like pockets most of it distributors and stuff um um what else okay so this is a long life update because um you know i
love to yeah but anyway guys remember when uh i really want to talk about this i even wrote this down because i was like oh i gotta talk about it before i forget uh but remember when you guys were asking me i was gonna go to twitch god and i told you guys like why i don't want to go TwitchCon and then like and then it happened it's like oh shit look at all my concerns and about TwitchCon and all my concerns and like my gripes about TwitchCon like came true like my I got vindicated yeah I got validated yeah yeah I was just like yeah I was like oh no I'm never I don't think I'll ever go to Twitch guy.
I feel like it's just mostly like I don't think it's worth it.
And then all that shit came out and I was like yeah I'm not surprised I'm not surprised.
I was just like yeah like no that seems right.
Like I felt like something I feel like I feel like every Twitch guy just gets worse progressively worse.
So I was not surprised at all.
Uh, yeah, um, um, but like, okay, there was one thing I really wanted to talk about, but like, bro, like, where did all these IRL streamers come from?
Like, so, apparently I was reading about it, like, I saw it kept coming up on my For You page, um, and it's not like the YouTube thing I'm just talking about, like, more so of, like, the IRL section, um, and apparently, like majority of convention where like irl streamers like like just taking up majority of the convention floor and i think that fucking sucks man like um and you know they're just running around with their cameras out and like blocking the fucking walkways because they're doing like they're doing some like you know content and shit but obviously you're supposed like the convention floor like no it doesn't matter what convention you have you ever been to a convention it's not a lot of space to walk around in general like not even for like streaming conventions,
for like regular conventions there's not a lot of space to walk around and now you have these people being their cameraman and like taking up like walkways and shit to perform some fucking content for their stream but it's like mature like but they take up so much floor space because they're all like trying to do something like trying to like make content out of IRL shit and like I really wanted to rant about it because i feel like the new okay it's a little sad but i don't know if you guys realize this but the new streaming meta of 2025 is irl like it's not about gaming anymore it's not about stream like actual streamed content on the internet it's just irl stuff like that's what na people love to watch like asia is different asia people still watch gaming um and like just watch gaming but I don't know if you guys noticed this but like gaming isn't a thing anymore for streaming in NA everyone just wants to watch IRL um and like I hate the fact like I don't mind IRL because I actually
think I personally this is what I personally think um because a lot of people want to be like the next Kai Sinat or like I show speed so like or like even the phase guys um I don't watch any of them I've seen clips of speed because I think speed is like a Kai is like up and down but like speed i think he's like super wholesome now like you know like as a kid he like you know he's still a fucking kid but like when he was a lot younger obviously he was just a child like so he um but i think speed um he actually does like really more like he doesn't his content for irl is much more like not intrusive like he's actually making like content and stuff like he's not harassing people and he um he's he's actually like making really creative content and like uh you know traveling around the world and like introducing people to different cultures and stuff um kai he has done creative shit and he also introduced like he i swear he is a hollywood plant i swear to god i just like kevin hart i i feel
like he's a hollywood plant like but like you know he's like interacting celebrities and like bringing celebrities and um into um into like streaming and stuff and like you know like he does have like very creative moments in his like i know he like you know he does a lot of banging for subs but his content he does have like creative shit that he does which i've seen um which i i've seen in like clips this i don't watch either of them i've seen clips of it and i've seen like um clips from speed i've seen clips of sky i don't know fuck shit i don't know anything about the phase guys um but they're really fucking popular now too because they're doing their sub-a-thon thing and people were i saw like people were complaining about why are they doing sub-a-thons when they're like millionaires which makes sense i know like i know like same with like unless they're donating some of it to charity um yeah they do high production value streams not like some of the other irl streams streamers.
Like this is what I'm like meh about about the other IRL streamers.
I know someone's like, oh, what about Keso?
He just streamed games.
Yes, but he's been, he's like one, I feel like he's the only one that streams games.
Like you can say like, okay, there's a lot of like other streamers that are like just streams games and still get a lot of viewers.
But like, not as much as the IRL streamers these days.
Um, but Keso is like literally the 1% of streamers right now that than the irl streamers of just playing video games um and also he's like he's pretty fucking funny too i would say yeah i i watched clips of him it's pretty he knows he's the joke but he like takes it like he he like uses it like he uses it as his like personality and so like he's like um um but yeah anyway uh and but like i i watched this i saw the clips I saw the clips of some of the IRL streamers that were popping up on my 4u page at TwitchCon and I'm like who the fuck is this guy I was just like I see like and they would have like millions of followers and shit I looked them up and they would have millions of followers on like YouTube and like their streaming so I'm like who is this guy and I feel like they popped up overnight and like and like something because I've like I've never heard of this guy before I was like is he relevant apparently he is and I'm like who is he and then like it was so gross because they
were like shoving their cameras at people's faces and just trying to make content and and then I'm like but it's all just rage bait like it wasn't even like creative they were just
like super intrusive and like there's like no shame yeah it was so gross i was just like bro what the fuck i don't know it just i miss the old twitch i really do because it wasn't literally i think it's just the n8 current n8 meta where people are trying or where people just want to watch irl streaming now um yeah and they're not really like like it's so easy yeah i know it's so easy to farm engagement and that's why i rage bait you guys all the time um but But I am,
my rage bait doesn't harm society.
But my rage bait doesn't have long-term effects on your psyche.
But it's like, oh, they're all just trying to make content like above themselves.
And like, because it's just like, oh, it's me, me, me, me, me.
Like, and it, like, at TwitchCon, it really showed that.
And, like, um, like, I just, I've never heard of these people before.
And, and it's like, it's like, oh, my God, I do so dumb cringe shit.
I was, like, watching, because I was, like, looking and they're like, oh, like, reading them up.
Cause I was like, who are they?
I'm like, am I not hip with the kids anymore?
Like, I was like, oh my God, is it me?
Am I not?
Do I just don't under, do I just don't understand?
Do I just not understand anymore?
Is this what they like to watch now?
No, you're right.
It's the student's fault.
And then I saw it with like, I just think, I don't know, I think it's cringe.
to like the cat like uh it's just it's just so cringe like what if you don't want it to be fit i think also like i think one thing also it's like what if people just because there's regular people at twitch god i feel like you know like there's regular people at twitch god and it's like these irl streamers are going up to this regular people they're not streamers you know like they're not they're not what if they don't want to be on camera and usually like a tv crew at a network is like streaming there's no it's so great the area is it's so great too i'm proud thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you one thank you for letting me know you're not a view bot guys um but like uh um like because like you know like tvs and network shows and stuff you have to sign a consent form if you get broadcasted like you know they're like oh do you want your be publicly shown on television and or like on you know streaming platforms or anything like a youtube video or shit but like streaming like
it's such a great area because you don't have to sign a consent form in streaming you're just live like they can just show your face like like i feel like i don't know that's a little
for now yeah like they um they can just say like show like they can literally just you're live what you gonna do like it's all happening live what you gonna do about it yeah no even then you if you're on network television if you're like you know or like on a movie set Television.
Or like, you know, getting interviewed and stuff like that.
You still need to sign a consent form if you're shown on TV.
So that's why they blur faces.
If you're like, you're doing interviews, and then the people in the background, they blur a face because they got the consent form from the person they're interviewing and stuff.
So it's just like, but like streaming, you don't have to do that because everything is live.
So you don't have to ask for permission.
It's really, it's really weird.
But it's like not everyone wants to be on camera, especially if you're at a convention.
I feel so bad for these people too, because it's like, that's why I was like, yeah, I'm never going to go to TwitchCon because I had a feeling.
Not never, but like most likely I wouldn't.
Because I feel like there's cameras everywhere too.
It just does not feel safe.
It just, it just does not feel safe at all.
and you guys were like oh why did you go and i'm like bro i knew that was i knew it was gonna happen i was like every year it just gets progressively worse and worse and i i had a feeling i was just like no i i knew like oh yeah and they make fun of random people i was just like i saw that they were like making fun of fucking random people that was just trying to enjoy their time at twitch con i'm like bro this guy might be like a fucking viewer bro and he's like he's so excited to meet his like favorite streamer like yeah there's some irl streamers they were just making fun of like random convention like attendees there and i was like bro like they just tried to have some fun that's why i was like i don't understand i don't understand some of these irl streamers i just don't but maybe it's because i'm not a robot and i'm a virtual girl and i'm not a maybe that's why sorry i had this was a 40 minute rant but i had to i had to talk about it because like um because it's just it was
everywhere on my for you page anything for views yeah um it's so rude it's like they do anything for views yeah like you guys consent to me making fun of you but those guys did not also let me get um i need to get tissues real quick and blow my nose hello dad also dad's home i don't know if you guys know that he's home
up I thought I bought more tissue boxes but I bought more top toilet paper instead um I'm gonna blow my nose with toilet paper I have too much toilet plate paper now all right I did not check I because I I got from grocery shop like online grocery shopping and I thought I ordered tissue boxes but instead I ordered More toilet papers.
Still paper, though.
Still paper.
You're right.
I'm stocked up in case we get the COVID 2.0.
You know, I'm prepped for COVID.
You know, anything could happen.
And a lot of things happened in 2025.
You know, I won't be surprised if somehow we get COVID 2.0.
Like, I will not be surprised.
I feel like at this point, like, anything is possible in 2025.
I do not speak it into existence.
Don't say that.
It's the year of sequels.
Anyway, so, disclaimer, that is a joke.
I do not, guys, for legal reasons, I hope that doesn't happen.
He, like, this is not me.
fuck if it does have please like i'll let you if it does have it's not my fault it's it's please do not witch hunt me i am not a witch and i did not mean for it to happen i'm so sorry oh yeah and then oh yeah sorry this has nothing to do with um covet 2.0 but like i can't believe jared leto killed the tron franchise i can't fucking
I should be really sad, but like one man killed the Tron franchise One man killed the entire fucking beloved franchise of Tron Yeah, it was like it had an even worse opening than Morbius like I didn't think it was possible
I didn't even think it was possible to do worse than Morbius Morbius because like Morbius people were like what the fuck is Morbius you know but like everyone knows not everyone but like I know Tron but at least like Tron had like a cult following but like but it's also Jared Leto so so like I swear to God I'm like has he made a good movie like like since I don't I feel like he has not made a good movie in a very very very long time also he's a fucking creep but like that's like a different
situation so yeah no to be fair he does have his own cult following too so I was just very surprised that allegedly Jared Leno lawyers allegedly you are a creep it was just all you know it's just stuff I read online like I don't know you know it's just rumors it's just it's just rumors i'm just a ha ha silly streamer um
um anyway i just wanted to talk about anyway so sorry it's almost an hour and now we're gonna do the real content uh i'm not a robot i've heard about this quote-unquote game and i've always wanted to try it out.
So basically, I'm here to prove to you guys that I'm not a robot.
And this is like the ultimate test.
And that I am a real person and not an AI created by the government to steal your data.
So I feel like this is like the one test to prove to you guys that I'm real.
And that 90% of people that are watching me are also not view bots bought by the government to make it seem like my channel's not dead uh dark blade thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i've been dead for like two months but as both your number one canadian and toronto chatter i don't know what your thoughts are on the toronto blue jays making the uh i thought you said mlp i was like my little pony world series but you're talking major league baseball sorry mlb world i was like what the fuck is the my little pony world world series um good for them i don't i don't know what else to say good for them uh i i don't watch baseball but you know yay blue jays uh juice uh juice caddy welcome to tomato farm welcome what sorry uh my algorithm had to i mean uh my real brain had to like remember what is the blue jays uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um to play this game quote unquote game i figured we had to play the right music uh uh the right music uh to get you know for the vibe you know like the what's the word the the the aesthetic the emotion of this game itself uh so let me play something real quick that i have queued up for us
I think I feel like uh the atmosphere of this yeah
by human music uh
there you go I got my human music on um I love human music guys I thank god Please tell me you're real.
Are you, are my chatters enjoying the very real human music that I have playing for everyone on planet Earth?
It's just, no, I'm so, wow, I'm so cute.
Anyway, I'm, I feel so human now.
Made of only the most organic human.
All right, what if everyone was a bot except for?
you yes fellow you i love my fellow humans are you enjoying the very human music we're playing tonight much fun much human zero one one zero one one zero oh my god if i was really fucked up i play ai gen you're right i should be playing ai generated music i'm not a robot all right see okay see All right.
Yes, fellow humans.
W, V, U, G, W, Q.
Look at that.
What?
W, V, U, G.
Is that W, V, U, G, W?
Okay, wait, maybe it's all caps.
W, yes, as a fellow human, I understood that it should be caps.
There we go.
vegetables, tomato, carrot, onion, corn, Mr. Potato, wait, eggplant, there we go.
Intersection, boom, beep, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, beep, beep, boop, boop, boop, beep, beep.
No, I got through.
It doesn't, beep, boop, boop, because I made a human error.
So then the captcha was like, oh, if you were a robot, you would know tomato is a fruit.
But they're like, oh, this person made a, this very real person made a human error.
So we know that they're human and I'm not a robot.
Just a very real human mistake.
Let's bring the human music down a little.
Is that better?
Can you guys hear it better?
Like, hear me better?
You know, like, captures?
It's not even about, like, what you put.
Like, like, real captures.
Obviously, this is a real capture, because this is a real test.
But, like, the other captures you do, it's not even about, like, what answers you make.
It's about the speed of your mouse.
Like, like, the precision and speed.
of your mouse movement.
They're testing that.
It doesn't fucking matter what you put.
They just want to know if your mouse is like a fucking like algorithm or some shit.
Like when you move like this or something or like precise, not like, because like that's too expensive to program, you know?
I mean, that's an...
What?
Oh my god, is this?
Oh my god.
Is this...
Okay, there you go.
what oh my god i'm doing a fucking puzzle oh it looks oh it's a dick wait okay no never mind it's like balls uh uh there you go we did it oh it's it's not sorry uh it's it's just a normal intersection it's a very normal intersection like it's a clover leaf guys i'm sorry i saw balls you know like when you're drawn giving a map and you just draw like balls in the pp like oh tic tac toe all right
there we go i did it what oh i have to win tic tac toe okay that's fine there you go i won i'm a better i mean i'm a better human than him.
Thank you for that observation.
Stop.
Select all squares with a stop.
Sign.
And bike.
Wait, is there going to be an in there?
Stop sign.
Where's bike?
Where the fuck is bike?
Where's B?
beep boop bop beep boop I know what you are yes a very real human just like you
see if I was like a robot I would have been able to be able to find the stupid fucking weird uh a good choice of music fellow human exactly my fellow human we love listening to this human music right now where the fuck is bike okay i'm downloading the alphabet into my system i mean into my body brain right now that's what you fellow humans say right one two three four if someone was like the sixth fucking row there's no bike here where the fuck is bike there's bikey there's um bicem but there's no bike i see two bs where is that where is another B.
B.
Oh, my God.
It's backwards.
Who the fuck reads backwards?
That's E.Kib.
Not bike.
Do I need to end as well?
Like, is this like one of those like, you didn't find end?
What?
That's messed up.
Okay, I don't have to enter the perpetrator's license plate.
Did anyone catch that license plate?
It's...
What is actually a real person's license plate?
Like...
Alright, stop.
So that all squares with a...
It's just...
What?
Okay.
That's like...
what?
Alright, that's fine.
There you go.
Is this cat?
It's like a little bit peaking.
Oh yeah, forgot the most important part.
That part.
There you go.
Oh my god, I'm playing whack-a-mole.
Oh.
Got you now, bitch.
Okay.
Where is Wall?
Oh, wait, I found him.
Guys, look at that.
My very human hands found Wall.
Oh, I love these.
These are so fucking funny.
When they were uploading my date.
I mean, when I saw this with my human hands on Twitter.
I'm just so locked in.
Locked in with.
Does this count?
I feel like it counts.
What?
Is that not traffic light?
Oh, without a traffic light.
like oh my god okay what there we go okay i'm not a robot i'm not i'm oh shit i'm oh fuck i'm um i'm i'm i'm a robot i used to be i'm a robot um guys it was just human error guys very human I just, I was just, wasn't reading.
Lisa, I'm a hot single in your area.
What?
Okay, okay, you guys didn't see it.
Okay, you guys didn't see it.
Thank God I'm covering it.
I'm a stockfish.
I'm a pop-up at 1-0-0-0.
I'm a voice.
I'm an elevator music.
Okay, you guys don't see this half.
Thank God.
Okay, I'm a spyware in the 90s.
I'm an instant.
secure thermostat i'm a barcode scanner i'm a cryptocurrency miner i'm a spam filter um i'm global positioning i'm literally a where is i'm not a robot there we go i did it oh parking oh shit i don't have arrow keys okay as a fellow human i know how to parallel park but i'm not doing that right now because i because that's too hard Let me go,
oh, oh, beep, beep, beep, oh shit, um, be, I guess give me this, oh, okay, wait, I'm going backwards now, beep, beep, beep, all right, there we go, see, look at that, bam, perfect, that's not parallel, it's too hard, right, okay, you guys want me, okay,
I, I can show you as a fellow human I know how to parallel park okay oh my god okay wait wait okay give me a sec I'll show you um oh my god okay wait my my wooden keep I just like recently cleaned my keyboard it was so bad I'm glad I did it okay okay I gotta do like the 90 degree shit real fast okay all right we gotta do this and then your your mirror has to be like see the corner of the other car and then you when you see the corner of the other car on your on your rear mirror that's when you go oh my god that's when you go oh my god up that's when you go oh my god um give me a sec Okay,
okay Um, oh my god This is fine.
This is fine.
Okay.
This is this is absolutely fine Okay
That's when you slowly back up and then Oh my god, we're doing it Okay I gotta make sure there we go all right person on my left side might not be able to get out of the car but that's okay I live alone that's okay there you go parallel parking
you're on the no no no I'm not guys I am on the right side Because I'm in Hong Kong, right?
This is Hong Kong.
So people drive on the right side.
So I'm fine.
I'm on the right side.
No, no, no.
We're in a different place right now.
This is an NA.
We're in the UK.
Guys, welcome to the London.
We're in London right now.
So I will be on the right side, fellow humans.
Like, girl.
Park the waymo in the parking spot.
Alright, I have the right of way.
Oh, oh, my God.
Oh, do you not see me flashing my two lights?
Okay, I got this.
Oh, oh, oh.
I told you guys I got this.
there we go easy what okay it's because that oh it's because i oh no okay wait beep boop pop beep boop pop don't worry my beep boop pops got this okay that should be it right yeah there you go perfect that was perfect joki that was a reverse not parallel
was so parallel okay is that a p or a b like how the fuck would i suppose it rotates or a d it could be p d or b oh my god they're having their own very human rave party um i that's hello fellow humans this is what we call a rave party isn't it uh use the context clues what context clues it's not even a real word it's all oh wait is this all caps oh my god you're right that's my context clue 4 e 2 y n okay draw a circle around this this oh my god it's a goddamn circle game oh my okay
eventually okay oh my god is this how is it i did it slower and it's worse oh no if i keep doing it oh my god oh my god how how is that the most accurate one it's an egg he a brick i smushed half his head that what the hell I just, I kept doing it until I eventually,
I told you guys, if it just gets, just smash your head against the wall, and then that's what your head will become, but it worked.
Um, at art school, be like, all right, fire hydrant.
Um, that's a fire hydrant.
That's a fire hydrant.
Is that a fire hydrant?
That's also a fire.
That's also a fire hydrant i guess that's also that's a syphilis i've almost said syphilis but i don't think that's the right word that's a fire hydrant that is also a fire hydrant that is a sideways fire hydrant that's a very tall fire hydrant um that is also a fire hydrant that is also a fire hydrant that one too but just oh that's a dog i mean that's an old man with a fire hydrant um the dot okay that's an interest oh that's a car we did it entered that oh my god this is some okay p u what h a p p u h a p okay we uncovered it we solved the case p u oh wait p you just gotta warn you one last time that level 39 will try to access i don't even have a web I think like yeah,
I don't I was gonna be like I yeah, no, I don't like H-H-P I was gonna be like is there any secret webcam except for my except for my um foreign government spy that's in my PC right now um you know H-A-P okay describe what you see oh this is like about descendant IRLs Streamer to your house at level 39.
What is that?
It's a butterfly.
I don't know.
It's like those like butterflies.
Roche's?
That's my federal agent.
Hello, my federal agent.
Oh, shit.
Um, we grab, we got the, okay, we grab sticks here and then, okay, guys, is it, is it it like this?
That looks like a pickaxe.
There we go.
See?
Alright, ducks.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God, ducks.
Get back in here.
Get back in here, ducks.
Get back.
Oh my God.
Get in here.
Okay, there you go.
Guitar cat.
What the fuck is a guitar cat?
B-pop.
What is a guitar cat?
I need to zoom in.
You see a cat with a guitar, guys?
How is...
Oh my god, I can be very zoomed in.
Oh my god, where's Waldo?
This is like, where's Waldo, IRL edition right now.
I see a drum set right here.
Where is a cat on a guitar?
It's there.
Did you see it?
It's you, oh my god, whoa!
Hey there, guy!
Sorry, guys.
I hope they're having a good time.
Hey there.
Over there.
Oh, I passed it.
I passed guitar.
I was too distracted by this couple.
I passed guitar, cat.
There's...
truck.
Stop with the creeping.
Oh my god.
What happened to our legs?
I zoomed in.
I had to know.
I had to know what happened to their legs.
Okay, wait, let me fix this.
I don't like that.
It's so zoomed in.
Let me.
Okay, there we go.
Made me very uncomfortable.
It goes.
Oh my god, it's not a goes.
Oh my god.
I found part of, I found his legs!
Just a couple of whiffs.
I found it, guys.
I solved the mystery of the missing legs.
Split up, gang.
Did you see it, guys?
Did you see it with your very human eyes?
Beep, beep, poop, pop, beep, beep, I do some live coding real quick.
0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1.
What did you say to me, Doki?
That's them zooming out.
Guitar cat.
I shall find you.
It's in a shirt?
I thought I'd be a cat holding a guitar.
You're telling me it's not a real cat?
I've been lied to this entire time.
you say above my motherboard?
What do you mean it wasn't a real cat?
I've been looking for a real fucking cat holding a guitar.
Why would that make sense?
I'm so disappointed.
Real life is just so disappointing.
It's on the orange table.
Okay.
Jesus Christ is so HD.
I mean these this table is oh my god I found him I found oh my god that's a cool ass or guitar cat I found you all right E F P F P T O Z L P E D E D F E what the fuck is that Z Z P okay what O Z L P E D E D I assume that's F right oh my god actually I'm actually squinting and it's just a picture um please complete the eye please oh the last row E D F E Z P what E D I'm squinting on like
Squinnah.
Doki can read and other lies we tell ourselves.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
I'm just making a very human error.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that a B?
Which one's a B?
This one?
I don't know.
That's an E.
Is that a C?
Oh, that could be a C, actually.
No, that's like a D.
Okay, I knew it.
Alright, please type the number.
Oh, I'm not colorblind.
Thank God.
Um, please type the number, oh, it's zero.
Wait, unless you're talking about this.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 23, 23, 23, 23, 23, 23, 23.
Okay, 34.
Because they don't have a dot right here.
I know what square is a different color?
What?
Oh, shit, it's this one.
Express yourself.
How did it know?
How did it...
How did he know?
I don't understand.
Is that not...
How else do you want me to express myself?
Oh, you're right.
It's because I have a nose, right?
I don't understand
Oh, do I have That's Oh, there we go Oh my god, oh my god, here we go It's okay Oh no Oh my god, now, okay, I can parallel park this Okay That's fine Oh This is fine.
This is...
Oh, no.
Guys, I can totally...
I can parallel park this.
Okay.
It's hard because I don't have arrow keys on my wooden keyboard.
So, like, I don't know what I'm pressing, technically.
Guys, it's fine.
I can parallel park.
Okay.
It's so fine.
I can tear this Okay, okay, we gotta We gotta do this And then we slowly Back up And then And then we do this And then we go Back Wards?
Okay, and then Slow and steady, guys As we know Okay, wait This goes this way, so This way we'll go that way and then and then we do and then we we shimmy a little bit like this and then we shimmy again and and then we and then we keep okay I'm plugging I'm in the other key i can't give me i need to don't i'm plugging in the other keyboard it'll be a lot easier i'll like crop i'll look at my keyboard all right the other keyboard is good guys i need someone outside i need someone outside at the back to like be like you know with their hands like yes just to the left to the right guys it's because i don't have like what the the guy that fucking comes out of the car to show me to give me the hand signals that that's what I don't have I don't have like a spotter guys it's not because I can't I I don't have my GPS isn't work my like parking thing isn't working the beep beep boop pop shit okay oh it's fine we're almost there I guess where's my hand signals where's my my my spotting oh my god
how am I doing worse with the keyboard with the arrow keys okay there you go okay and then like a 90 degrees there we go okay
with the 90 degrees and then Oh my god, wait Okay, and then Yeah, yeah, the stop!
And then move on!
Yeah, and then stop!
Left!
I don't have that!
It's not my fault!
Okay.
And then...
There we go.
Okay.
And then...
We go here.
Guys, go back.
Oh, no!
Oh, God.
I crushed my hand signal, guys.
I fucking crushed him.
I...
Thoughts and prayers.
The guy outside, I was doing the hand signal that has died.
Okay.
The spotter is dead.
I need a new spotter.
it give me a sec oh my god oh my god that was close all right we got okay I remember so you see it you see the end of the car at your at your mirror and then where the mirror calls the rear side mirrors because they're closer than what they actually are so you see that and then you slowly back out and then from that you have to The rear,
yeah, the rear view mirror, I definitely knew that.
And then, and then, look at that, it's so parallel.
But then we gotta, okay, okay, guys, it's fine.
How do I, how do I go backwards?
Okay, no, it's this way.
There we go.
And then, and then we gotta...
Oh my god, okay, we gotta go forward and
And then after that, okay, okay, just a little bit more, that's the, okay, um And then we gotta, okay
We got, this attitude's so close don't understand what
oh my god it's because it's manual guys it's because i'm on a i'm on a stick i don't know how to drive sick i i rented a car and it gave me a stick guys i don't know i'm auto all the way i don't know how to drive stick okay it's not me it's the car let's stop copie
well i see that makes sense i accidentally rented a stick guys i don't know how to drive sick it's a customized waymo it's there's no difference it's the car it's not me it's it's customized the chances of doing keep backing over you are low but never zero pop us for thank you for the super chat thank you thank you why is it going outside i need you okay okay is this good enough i mean i'm in okay i like yes there's like several inches um but like it's technically in like on a technical oh fuck i touched the line Let's see,
I got this.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, that would have been so funny if that worked, though.
Okay, if that actually worked,
guys.
What?
Guys, if only that worked.
Wait.
Oh, my God, wait.
Wait, I got this.
BAM!
I told- oh my-
Okay.
Alright.
Round 2.
It's so- Guys, I need to prove everyone that I'm told I am not a robot.
That was the road.
It looked like the road.
I- Okay.
i think too i shall prove to you all that i am not a robot that's a wall i thought it was a road this is top down
all right see a human would have hit the road because i'd be i'm texting and driving like a real human like don't text and drop by the way don't text and drive for legal reasons that is a joke do not text and drive oh god warning no all right okay
oh my god gaming i oh i could not have gamed this oh my i'm gaming i'm so locked in that all
my training arc is complete my it's the filler arc is over connect the network cables to fill all square what what oh my god is oh my god there's some fucking professor laden shit right now that i'm doing um okay it's okay i'm so used to doing these puzzles because i this was like Literally,
oh my god.
Okay, this was literally like Professor Lid and shit.
Okay, wait.
Okay, that's awkward.
Oh, this is awkward now.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
At the...
We don't...
Do we really need to fill all the squares, though?
Alright.
Then we got this.
And then...
There we go.
See, I told you!
Okay.
make 2,500 in the stock market as a fellow buying human um we are always obviously humans are the perfect way to make do the stock market um so um give me a sec let me um okay i should have bought
um sell buy buy oh my god wait wait wait we gotta wait i we can wait for this all right sell oh my god sell buy buy sell sell sell sell no stop peeking stop go down go down okay bye bye bye oh that's good that's good we can wait we're patient can wait.
Come on.
You go on and go.
All right.
Sell.
Okay.
And then we, oh God.
Oh God.
Okay.
It'll go up.
Guys, I swear to guys.
The market's not going to crash, guys.
We're the market.
Buy, sell, buy, buy.
Oh, wait, wait.
We don't buy it.
Don't worry.
The market will be fine.
We buy here though.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It's just something.
Someone got canceled.
But it's over here.
We replaced the CEO.
And now the market, and then we just least another star wars the market's going back up and we dropped another marvel movie um and it's like avenger 7 uh where we have like 50 actors now 58 listeners now um oh my god uh wait wait it's gonna go up i swear to god it'll go up guys just be patient sell sell okay bye bye and then we are in another controversy uh someone one of our directors got canceled on twitter but that's okay um we replaced him um and now he's in dc instead of marvel like doing better but that doesn't matter we have we're gonna buy warner brother did you guys hear that where you can buy warner like warner brothers is selling themselves again um we're gonna disney's gonna buy i swear to god i feel like disney's gonna buy warner brothers um okay sell don't worry sell we gotta sell one more time and i did it all right what was the level where it has the webcam shit so i can people select all the items with a soul all right soul soul the area stop sign 39 okay i'm on 30.
okay it's like i can do this oh professor laden time okay we gotta move i played onimusha that's all it is oh wait where is that
we gotta move this on this side and then there you go oh god okay um i can fix this um eventually if i move things enough it'll fix itself that's how it goes i just gotta keep moving the squares and it will eventually fix itself right um yeah and then Oh my god,
okay.
If I keep moving it, it'll go the right way.
Oh my god, wait, why is that on the other side?
Why?
I did it!
Wait, this has to be there.
And this has to be here.
So we gotta slow down.
move this all the way here but then we gotta move this on this side which we can do by doing this and then um but then we gotta move this here and then this here and then oh my god okay and then this here and then this here and then we got this And I did it.
It's all about the end result.
We're so bad.
It's about the end result.
See, I had a plan.
Guys, it might have taken a while, but I had the plan from the beginning.
I...
Okay.
Traffic lights.
The fact that I know this is not AI, too.
That's the...
I mean, it's everything.
It's all traffic.
Play the sick beat.
Okay.
What?
Oh.
Bum.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm playing that sick ass beat.
That's fine.
Oh, look at that.
All right.
N-B-M-X-A.
Okay.
Because I almost, I can't, I've almost felt that, bro.
I feel like me getting this, getting this right should prove I'm a robot.
Like, there's no, no human can do this.
Your confidence in the face of adversity is astonishing.
They gave me the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, this is easy though.
Says the fucking robot.
Guys, okay.
All right.
At chat.
At chat GPT.
What do I do?
Don't worry.
I have my fellow humans to help me out.
Um, my fellow humans working at chat GPT.
uh what do we do no okay which one is the least three eight three eight uh three eight and then what what is next three eight and then what what the factorial seven seven exclamation point okay what's next guys I know infinity is the last one because nothing's greater than infinity.
What's 3 pi over 6?
Is that...
Okay, 3 pi over 6.
And...
Wait, infinity is second?
How is infinity second?
What is greater than second?
No, 7 exclamation point is a lot.
Okay, so...
All the nerds in chat are fighting right now okay and then then there's us the regular humans um sorry all the ai's are fighting right now trying to figure out which is like which is the correct answer uh us regular humans are just along for the ride um the news knowledge is on the bottom right thank you for the super chat uh societal thank you thank you guys what's next infinity plus one you're right Log is the fifth floor.
What the fuck is log through?
Okay, is it this?
Okay, bottom middle, then bottom right.
Okay, square root of 19.
Okay, all right, what's next, guys?
What's next, my fellow, my fellow AIs?
Someone help me.
What the fuck is logarithms?
The bot is pretty low quality.
It merely tries to brute force.
everything in tattoo basic map shake my i am an entertainment i mean i am an entertainment human my programming my brain doesn't was not was not boring to do math middle top so this one uh the log one is two all right what the yeah the fellow entertainment human does not have the logs necessary to do math because i was not born in my dna genetics to do that my zero one zero coding in my very genetic dna it was not programmed to do math and by program i mean when my mom gave to me sounds legit toky what all right let's see what else is left e5 or set okay e5 this and this okay there we go we did it okay there's the ball here here here here here all right we gotta do this two more times oh um i fucked up okay it's fine we still have oh i had to go all over you okay it's all over here all right this is where the ball is it got a little too fast here you go i'm the moving that mouse is not helping me i got lost
what the fuck what the okay wait wait wait wait okay
all right I just need more frames guys this is like 30 frames I need like 80 frames or some shit
wait where did it go wait I blinked I had to blink where did I where did it go I lost like I blinked for 0.01 seconds.
I missed
it.
I missed.
Oh, it's a middle.
I knew that.
I literally had...
I had to blink for one second and then, like, oh my god, Beachwold.
Okay, win a game.
Okay, I have 30 moves.
Okay, that's easy.
I played Honey Pop.
I played sexy Beachwold.
That should be easy.
Yeah, I mean, that bad.
there we go the vine we'll just do that there we go sweet uh oh my god okay just put that here and then over here eventually I'll get a combo right okay 19 moves to get okay I can 19 moves to get a thousand that's easy
but okay here yeah this is a sequel the less sexy version of honey pop oh my okay triangle sweet uh okay that's a lot wait what do I do next okay I can do the red here eventually a combo way oh I already did hit the target they gave me so many moves.
Alright, sweet.
You know what?
Oh, I was gonna say I could keep doing it.
AI-generated.
Guys, I don't know.
What could it be?
They all look so real.
What could...
I don't know.
They all look so real.
It's so hard to tell.
Oh my... I mean, to be fair, I feel like this guy like, that's just... He's just too straight like the the face is just like too too centered and like it's like everything looks like perfectly sculpted in terms of like symmetry so this this one looks weird like i you're right it's the guy with the like i mean come on you're not he's not like glasses don't even look like it's actually on his face it looks so in ai generated and then Obama,
his ass.
And then, like, old people aren't real.
Like, we all know, like, when you hit 30, when you hit 40, you're practically dead.
So, like, there's no way the old man's real.
Like, wait, is that actually?
Wait a minute.
Oh, I was gonna say.
Is it actually him?
Wait, he's real?
Oh my god.
Is that actually white Obama?
Wait, is he real?
Is that...
Is he actually...
There's no way!
Wait!
Okay, I don't think this guy is real.
That's...
Is he not real?
Wait, that's white Obama?
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Equality.
No hesitation.
I thought you guys were beaming.
There you go.
I won my PvP, you guys.
Alright.
Oh, what?
How did I fail?
I can only pick one.
That's not fair Oh shit.
I got the double kill
Oh shit robot.
Yeah robot wouldn't go back.
It's not fair.
Why do I have to pick one?
There you go Wait what?
Don't get rid of my god.
I can only kill the grandma Oh, I got the little splat noises too
Oh, yeah
Alright, there we go.
I got it I got it Does it really okay, wait just to be sure Wait Do I have to put like the other times are fine?
Oh wait, that means I can do this double kill yeah quality there you go the other times they let me they let me park like this I like how the cops don't care as long you park like do the back parking I score guys I got more points right truly I got more points for that right I mean that's that's accurate all right now now we'll do this okay what did I do wrong oh you
mean I wasn't supposed to kill anyone that was an option I
okay all right grandma give me a sec all right you mean murder was was a choice
murder was optional who would have thought okay oh my god i'm getting better and better at parking guys wait that's a robot right there all right okay never allowed
okay i don't have there we go we did it all right i skipped it it was just like please show that you're happy enter the text below b k one b oh my god okay
b okay
One.
Oh, God, it's so fast.
Six.
Okay, it's a cherry.
Oh, my God.
It's the fucking cherry.
It's so fast!
Okay.
Okay, we got this.
It's the cherry.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's not even...
It's not even letting me press Z anymore.
It's good enough.
Grieve.
How do I grieve?
Oh.
I clean.
This is the grandma and the baby that ran over.
There you go.
I did it.
I agreed.
I...
Look, see?
I did feel remorse, guys.
And then I got the flowers.
What else do I have to do?
Oh, there you go.
I'm grieving.
F, I'm pressing F.
There you go.
See, I can feel remorse.
Hello.
I'm not a robot.
What's making you so sure?
sure because i don't work for the government more about what you think robots do for the robots aren't allowed to work at the government because they have no rights how do you think robot rights would change the world that's disgusting what what's the simplest about the idea of they are not human.
So they do not deserve rights.
That they...
How do you draw a line between deserving rights?
Human, not human.
Can you think of a scenario where that distinction becomes blurred?
No.
Can you explain why you are so certain about that?
Because I am not a robot.
You're quite common in humanity, aren't you?
A simple affirmation.
I'm starting to believe you.
What's the most human thing you've done recently?
Parking.
Ask chat.
I touched crap.
Yes, I parallel parked.
That's so human!
A robot chat parallel park.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Tokey instigating.
Yes, but robots can go to sleep.
That's the thing.
Was it parallel parking?
It was all parking.
You what?
How
did I fail?
I'm really good at parking.
Do you have a favorite type of vehicle to park?
No.
Because as human, I can park all cars except for stick.
You see how bad typing is that that's enthusiastic?
What's the most challenging parking spot you've had?
I had to try not to kill the baby or the grandma.
A dramatic scenario.
What made that parking spot so tricky?
that I can't double kill a morbidly humorous take on parking you're having this conversation with sorry Jenna say qua what's the absurd thing you've ever done while driving rushing my spotter accidentally they were the perfect chance for some great Um,
your mama jokes.
Jade, thank you.
We're in a super chat.
Thank you.
It seems you got a bit of a mischievous streak.
You think you've ever had a close call while driving that wasn't entirely an accident?
No.
What?
That's a bit departure from your humor.
Are you always...
Or was that just...
It was just a one-off because I'm totally human.
and we can have various react various ways of responding of various way respond resp there you go a sudden return to the earlier tone a bit of a declaration too you're certainly expressive can you tell me something that's been on your mind lately that's nothing to do with a parking i'm human you have how how pros are right you failed to prove you are you but I said I'm human I don't understand I I said I don't how did I fail if I say I'm human I don't understand not human is up all right are you a robot no it isn't because as a human i can't tell what's human and what isn't you're highlighting the challenges assuming humans a classic problem in ai are you not real like me who's a very real human being birthed by my real human mom and not okay yeah but the phrase is still feels a bit what do you mean I am talking very normally compared to you but the all capstone sorry caps lock is stuck very common issue I'm poor and can afford a new keyboard I need a dash of socio-economic are you
making fun of me because I'm poor no I'm just observing that it's a it's not creative I live in a shitty neighborhood um and i can't afford a new keyboard the raw odyssey is it it's my life
how dare you assume that i'm not poor and that i do not have the funds to buy a Okay.
And I...
You were making it sound.
It's rage-raging you to become you.
How do you assume that I'm not poor?
Is my life a joke to you?
You are...
Yay!
I did it!
It's working.
I killed Tripp the robot!
Let's go!
That was very...
How did that shit work?
Rage... I...
Rage baited me and it proved that I'm human!
We did it!
Yeah, I killed Tripp the robot!
It got to real!
Only humans are so tremendous.
Oh, I'm George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love Tokyo.
Yes, I fell apart.
I'm totally human.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I'm so glad.
Oh, my God.
Don't do this to me.
I had never done IKEA furniture by myself.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Where do all these go?
It's fine.
Oh my god, why is one circle and one, oh my god, okay, um, give me, give me a second figure out how to build IKEA furniture, give me, why is one circle and the other one isn't, okay, it's fine, that's fine, no questions asked, um, how do I, how do I fix this,
how do I, I'm so lost,
okay do I just okay we're just gonna put this on right all right and then and I assume wait where did the other one where did it go wait where did where did the stick go it's just one stick now what where did it go what did i lost in the boy where did it go okay um is this a shelf oh my god it's a shelf isn't it okay wait i think it's it's is it a shelf where am i wait is it though okay it's a table right it's a table um it's it's oh my god it's it's a chair right wait is it a chair what do chairs look like as fellow humans what do chairs look like my fellow humans okay um i'm on i'm totally on a chair um a human would use a chair yes a fellow human would oh my god wait wait wait okay and then we do that then what the where does this go okay and then we put this here oh my god i did it fellow humans i built us a chair okay i have not played chess in a long time guys i i don't remember how how to play i you know what's crazy i used to be in the chess club it's like wild wait which one's
okay all right yeah that's fucking right don't want to fucking mess with me now that's fucking red okay that was a little bit of i don't know i was just fucking her out.
Don't worry.
I'll just keep...
I'll upsmart this AI.
Um.
There we go.
What's he gonna do now?
You lost your...
Look at that.
Bishop.
That's fucking right.
I did that.
What do I take?
Why do I...
It's okay.
I don't need the knight.
The knight means nothing to me.
I don't fucking know.
I guess I'll go here.
Don't want to fuck you.
I'll go here.
I feel a little that okay i don't want to lose him though um so i guess i'll go here
i mean you can chill i guess that's not fair you can just do that that's not wait that's not fair what level is this what what level is this that's not fair
I gotta take my bishop.
Oh, he doesn't care.
Okay.
Okay, he doesn't care.
That's good.
He's gonna take that or...
Okay.
If he takes that...
I'll go here.
Wait.
No, if he takes this, I can just eat him.
So it doesn't matter to me.
Yeah.
Doesn't matter.
And if he goes here, I can eat him here.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is fucked up.
It's like it has a mind of its own.
I mean, if I take this...
Fuck it.
I'll lose a pond.
Why did he do that?
there you go
did he move
why did he not move
oh what did he do what did he do what did he do I didn't even see what he did what did he even do I wasn't paying attention I oh he killed me I wasn't, I was not paying attention.
My mind clearly was not there.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Um, that's awkward.
Oh, shit.
Can't catch me.
Silly.
Uh.
no guys is it sort of obvious that i'm not calculating anything it's you think it's a little obvious i'm just oh shit wait where did he come from where okay it's a little oh okay wait okay okay i'll i'll actually play for real i'll play for real that's my bad uh actually i you don't say Okay,
I've just been like moving things and hoping that like I can be silly.
Okay, bro, I don't want to think, bro.
I don't want to actually play.
Wait, why do I have?
Oh my god, it gave me two queens.
Let's go.
They knew I need help.
And they were right.
They were so right.
It is.
They actually gave me two queens.
i needed that wait does it mean the more i reset the more queens i get oh
okay no it was just one queen all right okay i i understand now
wait wait sorry sorry i wasn't trying to do that sorry i was around there i was like I'm sorry, I was fucking around.
I don't want to...
Guys, I don't want to think, man.
I'm not here to think, bro.
I just want to play.
Alright.
Take this seriously.
I just... I'm just messing around.
Alright.
Oops
Yeah, wait how many times yeah, too wait if I keep losing oh my god, wait, I got an idea
I got an idea
I got an idea Yeah,
wait wait Wait, how many queens can I get?
How many queens?
I have an idea.
I just, I have an idea.
Wait, how many queens can I get?
Yeah.
Eventually.
Oh, they won't let me move them anymore.
They won't let me move him.
Please let me keep moving my king.
Okay.
I just want to know.
They won't.
They're forcing me to.
Are they forcing me to play?
They won't give me anything anymore.
Wait.
They're at.
Oh, hey, I can kill it.
Okay.
I'm trying to see if I can get another queen.
Yeah, but I want checkmate so I can get another queen.
What if Alright There we go Four queens There's no way I can lose now I got four queens
Alright I'm gonna There's still a way is it It's five There's five queens There's no way I can lose now I have five queens
Yeah There we go god do i still need i still need a thing that's the worst part this certainly precedes the loose i think the worst part is that i still need a thing i think that's the word i i hate that i hate that cat just autopilot this that's right they'll never expect five queens oh fuck four queens they'll never expect four queens
You know, I'll kill, I'll sacrifice this queen so I can kill us.
I will sacrifice this queen So I can take their queen because I have three more queens at the four queens the five queens chat Because I know they don't have any more queens.
It's a sacrifice.
I'm willing to make Okay.
I mean, like, does it really matter?
I'll just...
I have a queen.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Okay.
Get that shit out of here.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
I didn't see that, Bishop.
Okay.
I didn't, you guys, still have two queens though.
Still, still, still have two queens.
It's okay.
I still have two queens.
I didn't register that guy.
Oh my god, did.
Wait, five, six queens.
Let's play.
I just wanted six queens, guys.
All right.
Surely it's, all right.
I can't lose with six queens.
I can't lose.
I'm not trapped.
Oops, all the queens.
It's all part of the plan.
Guys, guys, it's all part of the plan.
Six queens.
This is it.
How did you...
I just wanted six queens!
Is that...
Is six queens too much to ask for?
Apparently it is.
Oh my god, take it.
Yeah, that's right.
No queen.
now they didn't expect another queen no one expects another queen oh it's fucking oh my god wait if he takes me oh my god it's over it's actually over come eat it yeah that's all it takes that's all see six queens it's all it takes I got let's go I told you that's the strat chat you just I just needed six queens that's the strat it always works All right,
chat with Jessica.
You need to break up.
No, we don't.
I know I've been...
A little new number.
Who's this?
No, stop it.
You know it's me.
Don't play.
My name is Jessica and I just got...
Just got this number.
So who are you?
stop lying i know it's you don't i live in albert kirky kirky kirky and i'm 13 13 and my mom just gave me a new phone no way you're just trying to get rid of me i'll never let you i'm under age
stop don't believe you it's me a picture or or so jacob oh i did it i that's all i have to say
she let's how you make her leave the conversation i'm underage and she's like fuck okay
honestly you are spring yeah that's your u-fit i did it guys it's a very bold strategy but it worked uh what a pro okay the 64th floor all right one two three four five six okay okay one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve 14, 40,
50, 16, 17, 8.
There's no, this is not 64 already.
Okay, wait.
How many floors does the Empire State Building have?
Guys, how many floors?
It says, no, 64 floor of this.
Guys, how many, how many floors?
102.
Okay, so is this 102?
Or is this 102?
Okay.
Where does the floor start?
Or is this 102?
Where does the floor...
Where does it start?
Where does the floor start?
That's a count.
Okay.
60 floor.
Okay, here.
It starts here.
Okay.
How many floors do we have the minus?
102 guys guys how how many what where does it like how many floors do we have to subtract there's no way this is not the bottom that's the thing this is like mid height there's no way this is the bottom i refuse to believe 38 okay one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty 21 23,
24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 45, 36, 37, 38.
Oh, my God.
It's all the way down here.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
It was literally at the very bottom.
All right.
I had to use this as a guideline.
Okay.
I assume it's like here then.
What?
Okay, if it's not here.
If it's not here.
Then it should be here.
Don't make me do this, although.
Oh my god, if it's not here.
There's no way that's not the first floor.
This is middle of this.
Okay.
There's no way, because this is middle of it.
There's no way this is the bottom floor.
Look, there's more down here.
Okay.
There's no way.
One square is not one floor.
It's not?
Wait, but what does that mean?
Count?
Oh, my God.
One square has seven.
What the fuck?
How many windows are there?
How?
there's no way how many windows are there then it's like midway it has to be around here somewhere wouldn't be funny if that was it okay we're just gonna start here fuck it eventually it'd be 60 floor for it right eventually we'll hit the 64 mark i feel like it'd be up here then it'd be in the middle guys i gave up on counting we're doing trial and error the real here human way this has been how this has been oh my god it's just been they all the music all everything sounds the elevator yeah i'm like in the elevator and i pressed every floor eventually we'll hit it all right i started midway so like eventually how many tests are in here by the way how many
Alright.
There we go.
This should be it.
Okay, this should be it.
Okay, I feel like this might not be it.
I feel like I have to go start going down now.
Alright.
I'm gonna start going down.
I don't even know if I've done this part yet.
How many have I clicked?
I don't think I've done this area yet.
Wait, one more?
Here?
Down was not closer.
Oh my god, I was one, I was actually one away and I went down.
I, I can't believe it.
I was one away and I was like, it has to be down.
I, no.
I do this.
Oh my god, it's a rhythm game.
Okay.
BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM B not okay I oh my god when does this end there's
no does this end oh my Wait, when does it end?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
This doesn't end.
I have to play a rhythm.
Okay.
Like, I can't talk when I play rhythm.
Because it gets me off of rhythm.
Oh, my God.
Like, right now.
Okay, just film me right now.
Just...
About three minutes.
Okay, okay.
I'm locking in.
I'm using two fingers now.
All right, here you go.
It doesn't help if I have two music playing in the background.
It really doesn't help, I don't.
I think maybe if I don't have two music, maybe it'd be a lot easier.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Please Oh my god, I just made it I I was Oh my god, I just Oh my god, I just Holy shit A message from the inventor of CAPTCHA What does he have gotta say?
One of the inventors of the CAPTCHA More than 25 years ago We set out to solve a seemingly problem yeah it was the year 2000 and the worldwide web was growing fast but as it grew more people set out to take advantage of the openness that made the web so special uh-huh they created bots to send spam emails yeah that can't be me and even sculpt items on eBay we needed a solution I wait to tell the bots from the humans but what makes someone human is that our ability to love to feel pain and mourn the loss of loved ones we thought about it and determine no.
It's our ability to do what really matters.
That's what makes us human.
That's what makes us special.
And so we created the very first CAPTCHAs and put them out into the world.
Soon they appeared everywhere.
On forums and chat rooms before checking out, countless human lifetimes have been spent solving these puzzles.
Do I regret it?
Sometimes, but I did what had to be done.
Well, today I have good news.
Yeah?
You passed.
You are undeniably a human being made of Flesh and blood and so I'm granting you immunity from all captures.
You're free.
I did it.
No more ticking boxes.
No more clicking traffic lights.
Congratulations.
Now go live live.
I'm human.
Yay.
We did it.
Don't you I'm a real human being.
I'm human.
after all the station thank you for the super chat thank you thank i knew you guys didn't but i'm a real boy now i'm a real boy oh i gotta get my certificate so everyone knows i'm a real certified human being enter real real human you wait real human dokey bird okay save.
I got my certificate, guys.
You want to?
You want to see it?
Wait, let me open it real quick.
Here's my real-life certificate.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, look, guys.
Oh my god, it's real.
Wait, wait.
I got posters on Twitter so everyone knows I'm real.
I saved this into a picture.
Real human dokeybird.
Guys, look.
go ahead guys guys guys guys guys guys look i told you you guys didn't believe me but i told i knew it i knew i was real i knew i was real look guys
certified certified verified human my real human jokie bird you guys didn't believe me i knew They told me I was real.
Look at that.
It looks, it's so, it's so official.
Human certified.
There is no denying it now.
I have, I have, I got my documents, guys.
I, you can't deport me from planet Earth.
I got my documents right here, sir.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, You can't tell me to recite the binary code anymore.
You don't have the rights to.
Because I am certified as a real human.
I got a degree.
My documents are up to date.
You can't send me to the cyberspace.
I got my rights.
Angel, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Time to change your name.
Thank you, Winnie Akasufa.
Thank you, thank you.
Brady, thank you for the super chat.
This is more legit than the Dutch's certificate.
All right, wait, I need to upload this.
I need to let everyone know.
This is an important announcement.
This is a very important announcement.
I am a real human being.
There we go.
Not everyone wants...
I got my documents, guys.
I passed my human test.
Guys, now I am a human on planet Earth.
Dutch is real human.
A dokey bear.
Let's go.
She's real, I swear.
That's right.
I'm not a government AI.
made to steal your data.
I am a real person.
See, my Ochi is real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, solid.
Wes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If Doki is a human being, then how does she birth Chibi Doki?
That thing is not...
Okay, it's the mom, okay.
She's half human.
Thank you for the super chat, king.
Thank you.
Or she's adopted.
I don't know.
I was not really paying attention.
as to how it happened she could be adopted i think i think she was adopted uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you lylee thank you for the super chat thank you thank you congrats to doki ai for developing a bot capable of beating the test thank you for the super chat lylee thank you thank you that was fun i had um i went in the only thing i knew about this test was i saw someone doing the Empire State Building but that was like literally the only thing I saw from the I am not a robot um I didn't realize that's a fucking parallel I felt like I felt like 50% of this test was parallel parking that's crazy oh so the wild okay it was the wild gambit when you're like break up with your girlfriend and I was like I'm underage and she left and I was like okay yeah wildest gamble of my life and it worked I didn't expect even the AI was like we're not touching that that was crazy I was like I gotta bring up over fast I gotta say something even AI was like yeah no it I'm not touching
that at all like the nuclear option right there I went straight to time because of the chest.
I lost my, look, I lost time because of the chest, okay?
I had to make up my time somehow.
I had to figure out the speedrun tech somehow.
Um,
plays a real, real hero from the movie drive.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, 85, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Some random dude.
Thank you, but super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're only real as long as I skip my events even super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, everyone, for watching.
Guys, I had a lot of fun.
I would stay a little longer.
But we do have a fully packed week this week.
And I want to do a long stream tomorrow for the Doki Jam stuff.
So for those who don't know, we're finally announcing the winners for Doki Jam.
Huge shout out to the team for playtesting every game, as I said.
Some of the games that are being announced as winners, I haven't played them yet on stream.
So I'll be playing them as well as like try and play other games as well that in the Doki Jam.
So but like huge shout out to Team 4 playtesting everything.
And there was like a judge panel.
We had a panel to like talk about like who should be the winners and everything.
So yeah, I'm really excited to finally announce the winners for the Doki Jam.
For other announcements and announcements.
released a limited drop of the concert merch so uh we already had like one item sold out but we still have a couple more items that are still in the merch store um they are the limited drops that were that were at uh i should tweet i will tweet it out soon but there is a limited drop of costume merch that are sold at anime expo so this is like our remaining stock and stuff um the remaining stock uh from the convention so after this they won't be restocked again so we still have the I believe.
Oh, wait.
They restocked the buttons.
Oh, the buttons got restocked.
Nice.
So we still have the button.
The buttons, I guess they found more stock of it.
So we still have, we still have the stands, the tickets, and the buttons.
So yeah, please feel free to check them out.
We still have some remaining stuff.
And I will tweet it out later.
But you guys, it won't be, we won't have, we won't be re-releasing these items.
So, you know, this is from the concert and anime expo.
there um and this is just the remaining stock that we had left um what else yes if you guys didn't check on twitter i am in the maid cafe collaboration let me grab the graphic real quick i woke up before i could uh tweet this out so i'm grabbing the graphics real quick so i am also in a maid cafe collab um so i'm really excited it's been a i don't i don't think i've done a maid cafe like for my like you know that's like under like I had to show up for a made cafe shit this is my first time so um let me grab the image so yes gotta be at a made cafe collab because I've done like cafe collabs this is the first time I've done like specifically a made cafe collab so um I'm gonna be made cafe collab with Phoebe Mint and Lamo um there will be like I will be there uh doing not like physically there like irl but you know virtually there and there will be like performances there will be singing like i have songs that will be singing there um and then uh i'll like i think like uh all of us will
be there if you're like if you get a table we'll be there to greet you like we're like maids and stuff so we'll actually be there greeting the tables and stuff and also doing like performances and that's it on and then there's going to be food themed around us and everything um so it's very exciting there's going to be merch too there's going to be merch but the merch is sold online as well so uh yes apparently i have to sing it was so funny because okay it was so silly i'll say silly not funny because they're like okay we need you to sing a japanese song live like those like you know the moi moi koon and then i was like live what do you mean sing a japanese song live so i apparently there's gonna be a time where i will be singing a with with mint a japanese made song and like they did like they gave me like like they're like i was like i don't know how to sing this and and they're like don't worry we gave you a special video that you can follow they made me a special video for me to
follow along like they were like because i was like i don't know how to pronounce this and they actually made me a very video for a very special person i.e me to be able to follow along so i will be seeing a made song live there like with with mint yeah it's just made for me
so there'll be a custom food there'll be a custom like you know like it's like a cafe collab but for me made it's a made made cafe collapse have you ever seen like cafe collapse basically sort of like this but then there's the made feature where we'll be actually greeting every person um at the tables and stuff but men and i will be on certain date like i think we're doing it we're doing it together so men and i are grouped up together and we will there are only certain time slots in certain days that will be there so um if you want to get men and not you have to show you have to book a certain time slots because the other time slots are with uh limu and febi so you know um if you're looking forward to seeing us or you want all the girls um you have to stay at like you know like get make sure you get the right time slots and stuff so like just a little heads up for everyone anyone that's going there in person um because we are assigned to certain time slots because we can't you know
obviously men and i won't be able to do like the entire day
multiple days and we can't do the entire day so you know we gotta have our breakies you know we gotta have a little break in between and stuff so just giving you guys a little heads up um um but yeah I'm super excited about this collab um never done a maid cafe collab before so this would be interesting I know mint has done a couple of them before so um so yeah I'm looking forward to and I hope for those who are going there in person that you enjoy it too um like i said the merch is not exclusive to the maid cafe you can get it online um i'll i'll link the tweet out so you guys can see i don't know i think they're like announcing more details for it um coming soon so i sort of like gave some of the details already but i sort of gave but then like you know you get details of like that like we the time slots haven't been shown yet but um but
about just, I guess, follow the VTuber fan events account for more details, or just wait until I retweet it, I guess.
Like, if you don't want to follow it, like, I'm not gonna force you to follow the account.
So if you don't want to follow it, I guess just wait until I talk about it or quote retweet it.
Like, oh yeah, I'll show that.
And also, the, the merch, the exclusive merch, that the limited drop merch.
Let me grab that.
me grab that real quick for you guys okay here this is the this is the so you get it's like it's this artwork but for um before like in a ticket and in a ticket and also a standy so yes if you guys want to check out the limited merch this is what the artwork looks like anyway i'm gonna head off Stay hydrated.
As always, everybody, my fellow humans, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.